this video contains spoilers for Thor
love and thunder I am absolutely serious
we worked super hard to get you a Thor
love and thunder Theory up as soon as
possible cause we knew that this one was
gonna leave you with some big questions
and we wanted to get you some big
answers to those big questions but to do
that we got to cover some big spoilers
so you all ready great let's go
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that hopes your mule near that
screen so you can Hammer the Subscribe
button last time we covered Thor love
and thunder we predicted that the
trailer's use of the song Sweet Child of
Mine was a big clue that the whole movie
was gonna boil down to a plot point that
hadn't yet been revealed a secret baby
and it turns out we were right on the
money well maybe maybe not on the money
maybe slightly adjacent to the money you
see the big bad of this movie is Gore a
regular non-super powered alien guy
who's got himself a big old Vendetta
Against The Gods why would he have that
you may ask well shortly after having to
watch his young daughter tragically die
from dehydration on their desert Planet
he happened to encounter one of the
actual superhuman beings that his
species worshiped as their gods and uh
what is it they always say don't meet
your Heroes yeah Gore learned the hard
way that a lot of these guys kind of
suck and that all the prank that he and
his daughter did for her survival was
nothing their life of hardship utterly
meaningless but now that Gore has found
himself a magic sword that can kill the
gods he plans to do exactly that for a
little bit at least he realizes that
this sort of mission would take kind of
a long time you know bumping off Gods
one by one not exactly the scalable
solution that Gore here was looking for
so instead he has himself a scheme to
get the job done all at once thano style
he plans to find the cosmic being
eternity and wish all the gods away
because apparently the center of the
universe just grants wishes now gotta
admit things are starting to feel a lot
like a Dragon Ball Arc the only thing
missing are some Androids oh yeah I
guess they got them too side note is it
just me or does it feel like there are
way too many instant genocide buttons
here in this universe anyway because
they gotta wrap this thing up in one
movie Jane sacrifices herself during the
final battle the love between her and
Thor is enough to change Gore's mind
instead of wishing everyone else dead he
chooses to wish for his daughter to come
back to life but uh because he was
mortally wounded during the battle Thor
swears that he's gonna protect the child
himself which I'm now realizing is meant
to be a thematic rhyme with Odin
adopting the abandoned baby Loki on the
battlefield which therefore brings
Thor's inheritance Arc back around for
good and it's it's really smartly done
okay also my recording booth just really
smells like onions so like I said write
about a child being pivotal to the story
wrong about who but uh then again there
was really no way to call this one based
on deep comic lore because Gore's
daughter yeah totally new thing Gore
didn't have a daughter Thor doesn't
traditionally have a daughter there
isn't some popular alt character that
she'd easily map onto this is a
completely new unpredictable angle so
good on you taikawa TD way to be one of
the only people in Hollywood to have
original ideas the only other main
context we've got at least for now is
that her name is apparently loved she's
described as being a child born of
Eternity she has superhuman powers of
her own and she can wield Stormbreaker
so my main Theory today is asking the
question what does all of this mean I'll
tell you one thing it means right off
the bat means that Chris Hemsworth's
been giving away this twist for weeks
and nobody could tell that's my daughter
as well she applies the character of
love it also means that the real love
story in this movie movie was Disney's
love of recycling the Crusty old guy
takes care of the cute young thing plot
I mean hey if it worked for Mandalorian
it'll apparently work for everything
else literally everything else but
seriously you know what I love to do
after one of these movies look at where
all the pieces have landed on the table
and try to predict what Disney's next
move might be and between the
introduction of not just one but two
super-powered beings and Hercules in
love there's certainly a lot of story
potential here so what's it all mean
that my friends is what I aim to explore
today first let's talk a little bit more
about Hercules we made our first new
Powerhouse thanks to the god-filled
omnipotent city which was basically a
whole sequence screaming please go frame
by frame through me the heroes even make
sure to wave to an off-screen God of
carpentry I see what you guys did there
knowing how rationally the internet
tends to respond to the media they
consume I'm sure none of that's gonna
cause any angry headlines and plus that
I guess it means that Ghost Rider will
be getting his reboot sooner rather than
later but apart from being fodder for
like a million clickbait thumbnails with
red arrows and circles the other reason
for visiting omnipotent he was to set up
a post-credits scene that introduces the
demigod that lots of fans have been
asking about for ages in that
post-credits scene an angry Zeus is
embarrassed that Thorne company bested
him earlier in the movie and so Zeus
sends his son Hercules to go in and
please beat up Thor in a sequel now
obviously they're just setting him up as
a nemesis for Thor five or potentially a
morally questionable anti-thor thereby
making him a prime candidate for the
Thunderbolts movie that they just
announced where everyone gets their own
version of a Dark Avenger but there is
one completely Bonkers thing that they
might have planned for him that would
literally break the internet let me
explain assume we all just kind of know
who Hercules is right thanks to everyone
from Disney to the Rock taking their own
stab at him he's a hero from Greek
mythology half human child is Zeus known
for big muscles completing 12 Labors and
sometimes wearing a cool hat that's made
out of a lion well the Marvel version is
uh that pretty much the exact same guy
from the myths basically how Thor shares
a lot of similarities with the mythical
North store and when it comes to the
comics herk is kind of a fan favorite
second Stringer largely because he was
one of the earliest examples of Stanley
and Company creating a playfully meta
take on real world pop culture see in
the 1950s and Seasons the genre of sword
and sandal movies were all the rage
because of their low budgets and
shockingly high returns all a cheap
producer had to do was hire some
Mediterranean bodybuilders to fight in
skimpy togas in front of old Greco-Roman
ruins and then just watch as the cash
flowed in kids love the mythical action
adventure and the mom's bringing them to
theaters love the view so to speak the
most famous actor to come out of these
was Steve Reeves who's starting a whole
series of the sword and sandal films
through the late 50s and 60s his most
iconic role was Hercules and looking at
that iteration of the hero compared to
Marvel's version the inspiration there
is pretty obvious since then herc's been
an active character a fixture on a lot
of different teams in the Marvel
Universe and an on-again off-again front
of me to both Thor and the Hulk but how
does any of this apply to the MCU and
herc's place in it moving forward well
despite being set up as an obvious foil
for Thor in the next outing he might
appear sooner than that I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if he somehow
shows up in She-Hulk because well that's
been a thing before he can also make an
appearance with the Young Avengers of
all places considering in the comics
he's currently in a relationship with
the Young Avengers Marvel boy and he has
a history of teaching younger Heroes but
here is my wild swing for the fences
Theory this one is pretty crazy but
stick with me on it did you know that
the live-action Aladdin was actually in
the process of getting a sequel yeah I
was surprised too anyway the director
guy Richie recently stepped away from
that project I can't really imagine why
as expected he moved on to something new
it kind of got overlooked with so many
other exciting announcements that
Disney's made recently but he's now
doing a live action remake for Disney's
Hercules make sense going from one
classic Disney musical remake to another
but here's the part that really caught
my attention this remake is being
produced by the Russo Brothers the
brilliant directing Duo that gave us
Infinity war and end game that's a bit
of a weird pivot don't thank superhero
guys who's directing and production work
have only ever really centered around
action stuff suddenly working on a
Disney Live Action musical remake Disney
would also suddenly have two live-action
hercs running around which I mean that
that alone would just confuse people
what if this is the moment that the
traditional Disney movie musical crosses
over into the MCU a live action singing
dancing Hercules in his own adventure
who also moonlights alongside the
Guardians of the Galaxy and the Warriors
of Asgard all played by the same guy a
guy mind you who has himself a great
singing voice and a self-professed love
of The Muppets
[Music]
I mean it'd be pretty darn crazy but
then again three generations of
Spider-Man just got together in the same
movie so at this point anything is
possible and I do mean anything
[Music]
craziest crossover since end game a
Kingdom Hearts movie I mean that's what
happened last time Disney musicals
started a crossover with their other IP
I'm only saying when you hear Sora say
on your left seven years from now just
remember who called it who am I kidding
I just want to put this into live action
say fellas did somebody mention the door
to Darkness but while I was busy walking
out of the theater dreaming of seeing
edgelord Mickey on the big screen to
everyone else leaving that theater the
true star of the show was love enemy the
theory potential for a brand new
character like this is infinite to State
the obvious she's a resurrected dead
person and an adopted commoner being
raised by a noble I mean that makes her
symbolically loaded even before the
movie explicitly calls her the child
born of Eternity and gives her Cosmic
Powers really she acts as a merger of
two of phase Four's dominant story
threads big Cosmic existential questions
on the nature of faith in the universe
and young Heroes inheriting complicated
legacies but just because love is a new
character created for the movies doesn't
mean that we can't necessarily look at
the comics to find some similarities
because believe you me there is plenty
to see here enough that we can pretty
confidently chart where love is going to
be headed as a character see cosmically
powered kid is a story Trope that Marvel
Comics has leaned on a lot especially
recently plus Marvel's been using its
Comics publishing arm as a sort of Test
Kitchen for MCU storylines for the last
15 years or so which makes these stories
definitely worth looking at when you're
trying to predict what's coming down the
pipe in particular there are two that
seem to really match up to where Thor
and love are at the end of this new
movie the first is the creatively titled
Civil War 2 where we see a team led by
Iron Man and another team led by Captain
Marvel at each other's throats over
Ulysses cane and in human teenager with
the ability to see the future there's a
lot of disagreement over whether or not
to use Ulysses power to stop crime
before it happens basically the plot of
Moon Knight throughout the conflict
Ulysses power continues to grow stronger
until eternity himself intervenes
offering Ulysses a place to stay amongst
the cosmic Pantheon one could say that
Ulysses power made him a quote child of
Eternity just like how love seems to
have the potential to achieve Cosmic God
levels of power in her adulthood put a
pin in that one we're gonna come back to
it later the Second Story I think we
should look at is actually one that's
currently ongoing in the main Avengers
comic book it involves a powerful Cosmic
Force called the star Brand This is a
magical tattoo that Sears itself into a
host granting that person nearly
infinite power limited only by their
imagination but here's the thing though
the Starburst concept has existed in
Marvel lore since the mid-1980s it's
always been an unimportant alternate
universes but then all of a sudden it
was introduced into the main 616
continuity in 2013. in an Avengers
storyline called the last white event
this was done as a self-defense
mechanism for the Multiverse with these
white events zapping random Earths and
granting them star brands in an attempt
to stop universes colliding and
destroying one another in events called
incursions now where have I heard that
word before the larger the footprint you
leave behind the greater the risk of an
incursion Yep this is one of those
storylines that the MCU is currently
using to blueprint the movies it's not
stopping there the star brand has since
changed hands several times and in The
Avengers Comics coming out right now it
has ended up in the possession of an
orphaned girl named Brandy a girl who
wouldn't you know is adopted by The
Avengers including Thor and if that
wasn't clear enough star brands are
granted to the user through lightning
bolts very thematic for a new character
introduced in a Thor movie huh but the
real cherry on top of this evidence
Sunday this Avengers storyline and the
girl with the star brand are both
creations of writer Jason Aaron same guy
who created Gore same guy who created
Jane Foster's Mighty Thor and the same
guy who created the dead Celestial that
the Avengers are currently using as
their base this guy's fingerprints are
all over the MCU right now the way I see
it the most exciting option may just be
a fusion of both of these stories love
gets a star brand or Crips she'll be
revealed to be the star brand either way
this child of Eternity has near infinite
cosmic power which catches the attention
of everyone's favorite star cop Captain
Marvel remember she only Pops in for
matters that are deemed really important
for the universe's survival child with
infinite Powers Yeah it feels like it
could be a biggie this ultimately leads
to another civil war with Captain Marvel
and Thor duking it out over the child of
Eternity in Phase five or six I mean
there's already a whole episode of what
if dedicated to how much fun a Captain
Marvel vs Thor matchup would be the
writing is on the wall people that said
there is one final route that all of
this could go one that uh well I noticed
a few details that set off some alarms
it is a wild stretch but uh you'll see
one other famous special power child
storyline is the much older Celestial
Madonna Saga from the 1970s this was
written by Steve Engelhart whose work
inspired a lot of wand Division and
Falcon in the Winter Soldier here's The
Abridged version and I swear to you I
swear I am not making a single word of
this up mantis from the Guardians of the
Galaxy marries the ghost of an alien
tree who's reanimated the body of the
recently deceased Avenger swordsman AKA
Jack the sword guy that we saw in the
recent Hawkeye show this somehow makes
mantis the prophesied celestial Madonna
and her child with tree ghost sword man
is the celestial Messiah seems like a
story that's best left forgotten with
the 70s right well Marvel disagrees the
celestial Messiah is an Eco Warrior that
just recently returned in a central role
of the 2020 event series Empire now this
story was insane honestly I wouldn't
have even brought it up if it weren't
for one thing it is one of the
definitive Kang the Conqueror storylines
character Marvel is clearly setting up
to be their next Thanos the celestial
Madonna got introduced a lot of his
mythology it even featured one of the
first major instances of two Kang
variants fighting with the Conqueror
facing off against Rama Tut a version of
Kang who was a pharaoh in ancient Egypt
now all of this seems completely random
but Rama Tut has already been referenced
in Moon Knight with some Easter eggs
more importantly though they make it a
point in love and thunder to remind us
that Love's weapon of choice
Stormbreaker has a handle that's made
from groot's arm and that arm is still
alive sentient and evidently growing
when planted in the ground it takes root
who knows maybe that whole alien tree
Messiah stuff could be on the table here
too with love becoming the celestial
Madonna and Stormbreaker grown into the
character that's trying to woo her
sounds insane and admittedly it is but I
mean they're given Wonder Man a show for
crying out loud did you even know that
there was a character called Wonder Man
because I didn't so there you have it
loyal theorists the two new characters
introduced to love and thunder that are
gonna massively shake up the MCU moving
forward what's most exciting about this
one is that they built the biggest story
turn of the movie and now easily the
biggest new character turn for the Thor
franchise moving forward around a
totally new story direction that was
crafted specifically for the movies not
taken from an existing comic not taken
from mythology a new idea by the
filmmakers that is a huge deal with the
MCU of all things could become the next
place we start seeing as a source for
new characters and stories instead of
just bigger budget movie length versions
of old ones that is something that we
could have never predicted but hey one
of the things I loved most about Thor
love and thunder was its amazing
Aesthetics it was colorful bright and
most of all it was fun it's the sort of
movie that just makes you want to grab
its poster and hang it up in your house
and luckily with today's sponsored
display you can do exactly that disc
plates aren't just some paper posters
that you pin up with thumb tacks no
these are high quality prints on Metal
Sheets so they won't easily break or
tear if you're moving or just decide
that you want to change up the art in
your room each displate is mounted with
magnets so they're super easy to hang
and you won't have to worry about
damaging your walls it also means that
changing out designs super easy you just
take one displayed off the magnet and
replace it with new one did Star Wars
suddenly become cringed to you and now
you want to change up your aesthetic to
some one piece you can do that without
having to re-hang a bunch of stuff or
worry about your walls I wanted to keep
my walls recent so I switched up my Loki
disc plates for Thor it took literally
30 seconds and instantly it made my room
feel fresh again this plate has millions
of designs available with official art
licensed from your favorite franchises
do you like Comics or the MCU they have
thousands of designs from both Marvel
and DC more a fan of film and TV
displays got you covered with artwork
from Star Wars The Witcher and stranger
things really in the gaming they've got
more than enough of that one too if any
of this has caught your attention click
the link down in the description to get
25 off any one to two disc blades or 29
off three or more thankfully there's no
code no whatever the discount's just
gonna be automatically applied at
checkout if you click the link but the
deal is only for a limited time so go
check them out if you want some awesome
art printed on metal that'll last you a
lifetime again that is one to two disc
plates for 25 off or three or more for
29 off just by clicking the link down in
the description and as always my friends
remember it's just a theory a film
Theory and cut